today we're going to calculate the end
of the world our doomsday with maps yeah
since everyone loves edgar so much i
brought him along and i'm going to
explain it to you if edgar can
understand
anyone can understand you better pay
attention let's use some snazzy colors
so there's two versions of this there's
leslie's doom and and carter's doom
maybe there's more i don't know i it
kind of blew my mind when i heard about
it because at the end of the day it's
just using probability and
there are obviously papers disputing
these two arguments but there's equal
amount of papers disputing the
disputions or i don't know how to say
that so you know take it as you will
let's start off edgar let's start off
with leslie's doom i think that's my
favorite
you paying attention
okay so let's imagine that the total
amount of humans is n large n
excuse my handwriting
and this is the total amount of humans
to ever live
we're assuming for the sake of leslie's
doom uh that we will not live forever
then we have n i guess we can call this
your birth rank not sure entirely if
that's the case but it kind of works for
the sake of it then
if we picture an interval
from 0 to 1 where we want to find out n
that seems impossible right how can we
possibly know the amount of humans that
will ever live we just don't know that
but we can with a certain likeliness
calculate how many humans will ever live
so if we assume our fractional position
f
is evenly distributed
here
it could be anywhere baby if i had to
tell you edgar put where do you think
you live here
i guess we have to calculate with dogs
then i don't want to do that
where do you think you are
you don't know
you couldn't possibly know n could be
such a large number so yeah our
fractional position is n divided by n
evenly distributed but what we can do to
make it a little easier are you getting
bored to make it a little easier for
ourselves we can use the interval
0.05
let's say that's here
instead so let's say we're somewhere in
between here instead so f
is basically bigger than 0.05
we are basically saying with a 95
certainty
that we are
not the first five percent of humans to
have ever lived does that make sense
that guy
did i say that right we are with 95
certainly the last 95 of humans who have
ever lived within that group so
basically
same thing are you falling asleep this
is interesting okay uh so if we arrange
rearrange this we get that n
is 95 likely to be smaller than 20n
and we know this is where it gets good
again and we know
that 100 billion humans have lived
it's an estimate but that's what
wikipedia says and i'm going with it
please please
this is important and we know
with 95 certain accuracy
that 20 n is bigger than n the total
population that will ever live and if we
multiply that
with 100 billion so we are 95 likely to
never exceed what how would you call
this number 22 trillion yeah 2 trillion
to reiterate we are 95 sure
that the human population will never
exceed
2 trillion at garry
now if we imagine that each person live
for 80 years
and our human population stabilize is it
remains stable at 10 billion which it
currently adds is
so if we take the remaining amount of
humans
let me do this really quick so this is
the remaining amount of humans that have
left to be lived and if we take that
times 80 what do we get uh the original
one used 60 but i think the updated
number is 100
so 15
200 years we have left to live edgar
with 95 certainty what do you think of
that
yeah that's kind of cool that we can
calculate our doomsday that's kind of
epic right
what the [ __ ] am i doing
hey guys we have one more doomsday
scenario to calculate you want to hurt
you want to hear about carter's doomsday
as well okay and let's go to carter's
doomsday it's not as interesting but
it's a it uses a
cool cool thinking thing so if we move
on to carter's doomsday
what he says
uh he uses the base theorem which is a
really actually really cool probability
math equation it was used historically
in world war ii for example to calculate
the likeliness of the amount of tanks
that the enemies had in world war ii and
let's say you find a tank with the
serial number 500 you can then calculate
what's the probability of the total
amount of tanks that they had i'm not
sure if that's what they calculated
exactly but it's the same principle and
it's also the same principle as if you
imagine two boxes they all have balls
inside them that are numbered one box
has a hundred balls inside of it and the
other box has a thousand balls inside of
it now if you were to be given i don't
know let's say a ball with the number
five on it and we say that that ball
came from one of the boxes
which box do you think is more likely
edgar that the ball came from well
obviously
the box with less numbers in it right
that's just simple logic and we're kind
of using the same same logic here to
calculate whether we are going to get a
quick doomsday or a later doomsday so
the probability this is how you write
probability i've learned
for a quick doomsday before we know our
birth rank so when you calculate
probability what i've learned is that it
matters the probability before we know
all the circumstances so let's say
obviously if you don't know what your
birth rank is the probability for a
quick doomsday and a late doomsday are
the same
it's 50 50 baby and then this is our
early birth rank so let's say that a
quick doomsday would mean that we live
our out our time on earth oh we can use
the number that we got
before for that actually the late
doomsday would mean that we go out in
the stars in the galaxy we multiply
vastly by number a thousand times more
population will be born so
we have the probability before we know
our birth rank for a quick doomsday and
a late doomsday since we have no clue at
this point they're equal 50
okay then obviously we know our birth
rank is more or less we know that we are
among
the first hundred billion to have ever
lived right edgar we know that for a
fact which means that we are inside here
yeah
that means with our birth rank early
birth rank in mind the probability for
quick doom is one and the probability
with our birth rank in mind or later
is a thousand times less
since it's a thousand times bigger so if
we wanted to calculate the probability
for
you're the worst okay i'm trying to
explain this and i'm already struggling
if you wanted to calculate our
probability for a quick doomsday we can
then use base theorem so i've just
put a picture on it so you know i'm not
i'm not [ __ ] about it basically looks
like this
which gives us
plus
times a thousand
and this becomes a thousand divided with
a thousand and one
which is basically
99.9 percent sure
that we are gonna get a quick doom state
instead of a late doomsday according to
the circumstances that we just put out
so what did we learn here today edgar
that humanity is fun
but that's okay
what's that again
so i guess an argument you can use
against this is that well let's say
you're born norwegian oh it's five
million norwegians and how many 1.4
billion and so that means you're way
likely really you should be born chinese
but you're norwegian so i think what we
really proved here once and for all
edgar is that statistically no one
should be born norwegian what do you
think of that
[Music]
all right that's it thanks for watching
bye
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died